[Music]
we love and respect each other and honor
each other and you know that's the best
thing
[Music]
you know it's like my wedding and i want
to have a great time yeah we're pretty
sure teresa judice's wish came true
because her wedding to louis ruelas
looked epic
i want to protect our love bubble
e.t had eyes inside the big day so let's
dive in first up the guest list which of
theresa's real housewives co-stars made
it out
well we've got margaret joseph's dolores
catania jennifer aiden and jackie
goldschneider and even more from the
extended bravo verse
kenya moore dorinda medley phaedra parks
jill zarin alexia echevarria and chanel
ion whose son taj even scored a dance
with the bride
[Music]
our source says this celebration went
until 1am with a cocktail hour kicking
off the festivities after the ceremony
guests later moved into the reception's
main venue
which featured over the top chandeliers
flowers and yeah some moulin rouge
inspired performances
we're also told that louie's brother
gave a speech as did teresa's four
daughters who all played a special role
in the big day i would say they're all
my maid of honor i just don't have one i
have four of them the wedding soundtrack
was a mix of something old and something
new teresa walked down the aisle to the
iconic opera number ave maria but came
back to the 21st century for her and
louie's first dance with ruel's i get to
love you and she's like it was the most
beautiful invitation i've ever gotten
for bravo fans there were some elephants
in the room or maybe not in the room you
want to try to pop my love bubble it's
not going to happen
for example ramona singer who infamously
shared wedding details to instagram on
accident
i called her and i'm like
can you please take that down off your
story right now she's like oh my god
what did i do now is she still invited
yes okay yes yes yes also absent
teresa's brother joe and his wife
melissa gorga who co-star on the real
housewives of new jersey so what gives
it's like always other people gotta get
involved according to multiple reports
some family drama while filming the new
season forced joe and melissa to change
their rsvp status
instead melissa hung out with pal rachel
fuda who's rumored to be a cast member
on the just wrapped season but hey
anyone not at the wedding will still get
a closer look inside as cameras were
rolling on the big day for an upcoming
bravo special you know of course i want
the fans to see it because they've been
on this journey with me so and of course
i want them to see it i really do
[Music]
you